you know it's been almost a year since
our staff started working remotely
i really miss seeing everyone around the
office so i'm going to check in with
some staffers who are working from home
and see what's new since the last time i
saw them
hey diane what's new with you well i got
a phd in astrophysics and i'm currently
manning the mars rover
perseverance collect the geology samples
oh
that's cool what about you chris we
bought a zoo
and our elephant just gave birth oh okay
what about you kathy i got a tattoo
that's nice that's all you're gonna say
well i
guess so many things have happened in
the last year that nothing really
surprises me anymore
uh i bet i can surprise you conan jake
from state farm i'm here to tell you
about surprisingly great rates from
state farm
how can we compete with that jake how
great are these surprisingly great
rates check your inbox
are you kidding me i'm so surprised by
these great rates
these rates are unbelievable i am losing
my mind
over these great rates take from state
farm
you did it again yeah jake really did do
it again